I have one suit my brown Sears three
piece
Elise yarkton Elaine's
Elaine's let me do that again
sorry that's stupid okay you don't even
know one thing I didn't even say what
they gonna do she asked me the whole
thing and I didn't even do it once I'm
like an elephant okay if I walk into a
room it's like okay he's in there
Baba Boy
turn this music down
[Music]
um
sometimes when I wipe
I'll wipe and I'll wipe and I'll wipe
and I'll wipe a hundred times still poop
still poop let me check that it's like
I'm wiping a marker or something
will you just help me open this
it's a really
thanks
what I was saying is that awesome girls
like you who are you know not
classically hot they can go and they can
be rewarded for
an idiot
so
um
so I uh
[Music]
Leslie doesn't like to hear her mommy
talk about sex
no one wants to hear that why don't you
tell us about your eska pigs you little
minks
I felt like oh maybe
there could be something with our
characters was actually the last episode
of the first season
so what kind of music does your band
play you know I don't really like to
Define it but it's like Matchbox 20
meets The Fray so rock well again I
don't really like to Define it so
undefinable rock you know again the term
Rock I think defines it I totally know
what you mean in that moment I was like
I feel like April would think Andy is
really cute maybe that'll be something
every person
you saw your head okay
everything I'm sorry
Andrew I need evidence got it wait you
don't know what evidence ah right on yes
hit me next to my desk is a picture of a
female politician Bella abzuk is that
scary face funny hat gap tooth or Bill
Clinton's wife funny hat funny hat on
the back of it is a key taped to it and
then that opens my bottom drawer and my
desk get
it
tutorial
you got bored in the middle of it
[Music]
oh [ __ ] that's funny okay okay
no I am I'm in love with you because
you're just like me you're a dog date me
and I'm single
Ron you're gonna construct the stage yes
ma'am
I really think we should try and involve
this talking dog
remember when we had sex in the gutter
on Rodney Street I'll never forget it
Dad
come over there and [ __ ] you up
I have hot snakes you guys what's hot
when the diarrhea comes out like a hot
snake candy
I get hot snakes and bubble guts
I know where you live 14th Street right
I am going to get a melon baller and
scoop your eyes out and eat them and
your Congressman uncle's gonna have to
buy you a [ __ ] dog to drag your
eyeless face around you understand me
kiss me kiss me don't [ __ ] get near
me
don't
don't
do that
yeah I love cupcakes
I always hate you Annie has herpes
problem my problem is you smell us Ben
told you to finish the website and if
you don't do it I swear to God I'm gonna
murder you in your sleep I know where
you live 14th Street right I'm gonna get
a melon baller and scoop your eyes
and your Congressman uncle's gonna have
to buy you a dog to drag your eyeless
face around
do you understand
do it okay